[Music]
Disney Princesses are some of the most
popular characters in the world but have
you ever wondered what they would look
like if they were Space Marines or
perhaps superheroes and just wait until
you see Mulan reimagined as the girl
from the ring hit that subscribe button
for more amazing Disney topics and don't
forget to give this video a big thumbs
up today we're checking out 10 Disney
Princesses reimagined by amazing artists
Snow White and Pocahontas at Coachella
let's start with the real world we've
already covered the amazing evolution of
the Disney Princesses but have you ever
imagined them attending real-life events
check out ND comics in who turns
celebrities into disney princesses here
we have Snow White and Pocahontas
jamming out at Coachella the record
breaking Music Festival with the
attendance of a hundred and ninety-three
thousand people if Disney Princesses
would actually exist they would
definitely attend Coachella for the
weekend and enjoy letting loose who with
their favorite artists see we can see
Pocahontas enjoying the sound of Lord
although we can't quite imagine Snow
White listening to the modern-day music
while we have no doubt that Pocahontas
would be able to handle Coachella and of
a party of her own Snow White at
Coachella is a whole other subject of
discussion but who knows perhaps a
modern Snow White would have another
side to her speaking of Disney and
Coachella someone decided to redesign
the original Coachella lineup poster and
created the ultimate dissing Coachella
lineup which one would you prefer the
artists you normally listen to at this
festival or would you prefer Hannah
Montana the Jonas Brothers and Hilary
Duff needless to say this poster surely
brings us the best of both worlds
erielle as Black Widow now this is the
movie we'd love to see with her long red
hair Arielle very easily fits with every
character including Black Widow
we are totally loving this design done
by the very talented Isiah Stephens we
all know that Black Widow had another
secret identity in the early 40s but
Arielle could definitely pass as another
well-kept black widows secret black
widows fiery hair isn't that different
from Ariel so perhaps this is why this
combination isn't that hard to imagine
after all we are loving her sassy boots
since she totally looks like she's ready
to
some serious but having Ariel as a black
widow would also give her an extra power
after all Ariel is able to live
underwater that should probably come in
handy in the black widows world too
right how do you think Ariel would do in
the action-filled world we'd love to see
her attend a black widow style boot camp
and watch her transform into this
powerful Russian Marvel character the
feisty and strong-headed little mermaid
is definitely one of the best characters
to portray Black Widow who knows she
might even have a few hidden fighting
skills we don't even know about
Pocahontas as Katniss Everdeen speaking
of Disney Princesses picking serious
fights this would be one of the coolest
things to see this awesome illustration
was done by the same artist who designed
Ariel as Black Widow and he can't get
over how awesome it looks Katniss
Everdeen is only 16 in the first Hunger
Games trilogy while Pocahontas is 18
although Pocahontas really isn't known
for her fighting spirit we can't imagine
she'd have no problem fitting into this
role the dude don't really share many
similarities but for some reason
Pocahontas definitely looks like she
could play the part of Katniss Everdeen
okay maybe we lied there are a few
common threads with the two characters
come to think of it doesn't Jennifer
Lawrence kind of look like Pocahontas
the actress who plays Katniss Everdeen
has been compared to many Disney
Princesses
but the Pocahontas comparison might be
just our favorite one yet don't they
look similar the quote she goes wherever
the wind takes her could definitely
apply to both of them both characters
also highlight the importance of love
what do you think Pocahontas would
choose if she was in Katniss's plays
would she go with Gale or Peeta Snow
White as a mermaid Disney shows us our
imagination has absolutely no limits and
these people have definitely used their
imagination in the best way possible
Snow White as a mermaid yes please
doesn't you look absolutely amazing you
can create your own Disney mermaid at
azalea's dolls calm the original Snow
White would never step anywhere near the
water but maybe this illustration could
give Disney a new story idea we're used
to seeing Snow White's curly hair but
her underwater hair is surprisingly just
as awesome both Snow White and Ariel
were born into royalty so that part of
her life wouldn't be that different what
her high-pitched voice fit into the
world of The Little Mermaid
see how snow-white spin doesn't have the
same color as Arielle's it's because
erielle spin is one of a kind the
blue-green color you see was even named
after her
Ariel's red hair was chosen because it's
a complementary color to the green wood
the black haired snow-white have the
same effect we still can't get over Snow
White's hair underwater it's absolutely
stunning did you know that Snow White is
also the only Disney Princess with her
very own Hollywood Walk of Fame star
Belle as a Space Marine here's something
completely unpredictable to make your
imagination reach new heights fell as a
Space Marine an Australian game
developer called MRC Denise decided to
combine the two worlds and created what
looks like an almost impossible
illustration if you're not familiar with
Space Marines here's a quick lowdown
Space Marine characters belong to a
miniature science fantasy game and these
characters look incredibly awesome but
could a Disney Princess Rock the Space
Marine look this game developers sure
think so and we can't help but to love
this illustration Belle is a scary
defender of humanity now that would be
an interesting plotline she'd no longer
be immortal she'd be a superhuman ready
to take on just about anyone Gaston
would never stand a chance but perhaps
neither would anyone who makes Belle to
Space Marine angry there would be no
more songs no more gentle and innocent
Belle the Beauty and the Beast roles
would definitely change well with the
beast think of his transformed version
of Belle Beauty and the Beast was
created by 600 amazing animators and
artists but just how many artists do you
think it would take to create Belle as a
Space Marine Merida as a part of the
Taylor Swift squad Merida is one of the
most beloved and unique Disney
Princesses out there so of course it
would make sense that she becomes a part
of the Taylor Swift squad right she's
clever she's adventurous and most
importantly she's brave and trust us you
don't want to mess with Merida
especially not after seeing this awesome
poster that could very well be real a
very talented artist that goes by the
name of Pauline is known to design
amazing modern-day princesses and Merida
being a part of Taylor Swift's music
videos seems like an appropriate move
her big hair makes her look even fiercer
than usual and the artist gave her a
brand new name to go with her new feisty
personality Artemis everyone's favorite
Archer is definitely ready
for some serious business and we'd love
to see her fighting skills in this music
video which other Disney Princesses do
you think could also become a part of
the Taylor Swift squad or thinking Elsa
from frozen might just be the perfect
fit
the next princess on our list would also
be suitable what we think this character
might suit her even better can you guess
which princess is next on our list
Cinderella as a superhero did you know
that Cinderella is the very first Disney
Princess that married into a royal
family instead of being born into it her
original name means the little ash girl
but she has proven to everyone that she
is much more than that this amazing
artist whose name is Lady Aqua 9 took
Cinderella to the next level and turned
her into an awesome superhero that's
ready for anything life throws her way
just look at her doesn't she look
amazing we love how the artist stuck to
the original Cinderella outfit but just
made it a billion times better what do
you think with this Cinderella still fit
into the original storyline or would
things change in the kingdom she sure
does look amazing we've mentioned before
that Disney seems to follow a theme of
putting off her gloves on princesses who
have married into a royal family instead
of being born into one and this artist
seems to have known this - the 2015
Cinderella movie has even more facts
about Cinderella's clothing did you know
that it took about four thousand hours
to make all eight versions of the
princess's gowns
the dress was so complex it took the
actress about 20 minutes to put it on
but this would never be an issue if
Cinderella was actually reimagined as a
superhero
Elsa as a vampire deviantART artists are
absolutely amazing and we love how they
are able to completely redesign a
character but turn into a real thing to
check out Elsa reimagined as a vampire
this image was done by the deviantART
artist called egg Yulan pretty cool huh
also has such an iconic braid that the
design team behind it had to bring out a
brand new software to make sure they
reach that perfect hairstyle so what do
you think of Elsa as a vampire her hair
is dark red as are her eyes and she had
some cool-looking bangs this redditor
shared a very interesting theory about
Elsa
he said that Elsa is the queen of winter
and Anna is the queen of summer although
Elsa's powers are clearly much stronger
than Anna's they had to create Olaf
together
is this why Olaf wants to experience
summer so badly another user suggested
that Ana might have spring powers
instead of summer powers as spring as a
symbol of growth and birth throughout
the movie and his wardrobe was also
mainly green and as you know green is
usually associated with spring we
certainly agree with this theory but if
Elsa would originally be a vampire what
do you think that would make Anna could
she be a werewolf
Mulan as the girl from the ring we've
seen Arielle as the Black Widow we've
seen Merida as a part of the Taylor
Swift squad we've even seen Pocahontas
and Snow White at Coachella Cinderella
and Elsa also made an appearance which
do sea princess are we missing
it's Mulan this illustration was done by
the very talented Travis foul again we
hope you don't get scared easily because
this version of Mulan isn't very
friendly for the eyes meet Mulan
reimagined as a scary girl from the ring
horror movie well now this is something
you don't see every day and we
definitely don't want to see it come to
light who would have thought that the
independent warrior could so easily play
the part in a horror movie we're very
glad this is not what Mullins face
actually looks like but perhaps the
reflection song lyrics might still make
sense
speaking of reflection did you know that
Mulan actually launched Christina
Aguilera singing career the famous pop
star was signed to a label after they
heard reflection and the rest is history
how would Mulan story turn out if she
actually did look like the ring girl
she'd definitely be the most interesting
princess ever although we doubt she
could beat Mulan's popularity jasmine as
a real-life princess and last but not
least is the beautiful Princess Jasmine
reimagined as a real-life princess this
illustration comes from a very talented
artist called Isabel this is what
happens when you combine modern artists
with classic Disney you redesign Disney
Princesses like you've never seen them
before we really can't get enough of
this refreshed looking Jasmine don't you
love the detail from her brown eyes and
her highlighted hair to the added
lighting on her cheek this illustration
makes Jasmine just a bit more defined
and lifelike Jasmine is the second
youngest Disney Princess right after
Snow White she's actually so beautiful
the designers had to redesign Aladdin to
get on her level did you know that
Princess Jasmine actually has quite a
look-alikes check out this Atlanta based
model and singer who might as well be
the real life Princess Jasmine
we're so jealous she dressed as jasmine
for Halloween and she definitely nailed
it and it's not just the costume she
looks like Princess Jasmine even without
it but she's not the only one
Nicole Scherzinger is also frequently
noted as the Jasmine look-alike just
look at her channeling her inner Disney
Princess who do you think looks like
Jasmine more which is your all-time
favorite Disney Princess and why let us
know in the comments below don't forget
to hit that like button if you're a true
disney fan and subscribe to our channel
for more disney videos check out 15
disney princesses reimagined by amazing
artists part 1 thanks for watching
[Music]